we want you all to have a great time I
know it looks like we have a cash bar
tonight but as I promised you in the
invitation at a later date I will get
Mexico to pay for all your drinks this
comedian Samantha be in 2017 hosting the
not the White House Correspondents
Dinner for the first time it was her
alternative to the official event
honoring political reporters although
political reporters don't think they up
do it to honor themselves the real White
House Correspondents Dinner is this
Saturday in Washington once again
President Trump will not attend and
instead of a comedian a historian Ron
chernow will be the featured speaker so
for the second time the host of
full-frontal is Samantha B will host her
own dinner to air at the same time
Samantha good morning thank you so much
for having me so after you did the first
one the first not the one you said I'm
not gonna do this again yeah I didn't
think that it would be necessary but it
turns out now that we're not having a
comedian at the dinner it felt like it
was time to your answer now a national
call it's a nationally doing the Lord's
work and so what can we expect long list
of celebrities long list of special
guests we're doing some great music I
mean ultimately we're honoring
journalists and and journalism is under
siege for sure so we want to highlight
that but ultimately we really want to
have a fun night we want to provide an
alternative event that is joyful and
celebratory and ridiculous and all the
things that go into it don't we need fun
too I mean the country is so divided we
need to end so nasty and so mean so how
do you navigate those waters how do you
know how far you can go to the line
without crossing it well as you know
Gayle big believer and the grand old
First Amendment so you know we pushed
limits on our show for sure but we work
our way through very difficult material
and we try to highlight things that are
important to us but we bring humor to it
too we think I feel like it's a way for
people to get to understand or or
process the things that are happening
right now which can be very devastating
stating I think through the lens of
humor is a good way for people to how
long have you been doing political humor
I've been doing it for so long yeah I
think it says in the notes
sixteen years ten years yeah how do you
think it's changed in that time that
you've done it and how has it changed
under this president
well it's changed a lot under this
president I mean the volume of the
volume of news that we're handling is it
feels insurmountable
it's sifting water from a fire hose it
really is it's like it is like a like a
like a firehose of news we don't you
know we're not spending the amount of
time that we used to on when I worked at
The Daily Show we would you know process
stories this thing that over those games
yeah it's very difficult to do that when
things keep coming at you so then is the
challenge for to me creating good comedy
not swinging at every single pitch you
can't swing at every single pitch we're
lucky was we only are on once a week so
we get to sit back and kind of in
process take it all a little bit take it
the best pitches take the best pitches
and and do it and sit back and do a
little bit more analysis so I feel lucky
to not have to do it every day
mm-hmm sorry Kay yeah Mulla report
Samantha bee oh how did you do that yeah
cause I it's a difficult one I'm not
sure that people I mean people have been
really groomed people are really being
groomed in this administration do you
not take things seriously and to not let
stories sit with them and to not let
things stick and I find that very
distressing it's incredibly distressing
because we keep hearing people want to
know about it but then we hear people
are tired of it too tired of it so I
wonder how you navigate I don't know
have you navigated we just have to keep
bringing these things that we just have
to keep presenting them to people and
hoping that they will there are 20
Democrats running for Senate for
president sorry running for president a
new one may have announced since I
started this centos likely what does
that is that a gift that it will be a
very interesting year and a half
leading into it's already so exact yeah
I do feel like people should really want
to be President if they're going to run
for president these days I feel like
we've had an
accidental president somewhat and I do
think that if you're gonna run for it
you should want to do the actual job not
just sell a book that's my standard you
have senator Warren for the first time
last night saying that they should take
steps towards potentially impeaching the
present United States yes whereas
Speaker Pelosi has sort of put the
brakes on what do you make of that
divide within the Democratic Party
there's well there's always infighting
and within the Democratic Party that's
what we're very good at so we'll see how
it will see how it shakes out but I feel
like people need to take this report
seriously and really sit with the
implications of it and I'm not sure that
we're capable of doing that they says do
you ever think this is this not the
malla report or anything else it's too
serious to joke about well of course
there are definitely things that are too
serious to joke about and we don't joke
about those things but we find our line
as we get to it you know what I mean we
don't like we don't have an agenda on
the show that's like this is this feels
off topic for us we just take every
story that feels important to us and
then figure out if there's a path
through it that we can make on the show
and if there is no path than we leave it
to frontline but don't you know you will
never run out of material we will never
say literally you'll always have a job
Democratic president Republican
president there's never a lot of
material there's no unfortunately our
path has come to it we'll just have to
watch on Saturday is closed here but
continue on Saturday not the White House
Correspondents Dinner airs Saturday on
TBS